dan and Boyer celebrates two big
milestones coming out publicly and
marrying the man of his dreams
the younger star who played Hilary
Duff's fiancee fed on the TV Land series
said I do in real life to your love may
it be wild beautiful dangerous and
majestic dan wet his longtime boyfriend
37 year old financier aaron berger on
saturday according to people he posted a
sweet instagram snap kissing his new
husband during their first dance
captioned so we got married today the 31
year old actor explained why he kept his
sexuality a secret until now
telling the mag quote being a young
actor in the industry I had a lot of
people who strongly advised me to stay
quiet
he added that was hard to live with but
I've never played a gay role before and
I didn't want to be limited by some
strange perception dan also admits his
co-star Nikko Tortorella inspired him to
finally come out since he's an advocate
for sexual fluidity doesn't matter how
you identify what label you fit under
the sooner we all treat every single
person as an individual the happier this
this place will be
you